today on the matt walsh show
conservatives celebrate as the women's
swimming federation officially
disqualifies men like leah thomas from
competition in the future does this mark
a return to sanity in our culture uh
actually no it doesn't and i'll explain
why also the new woke toy story film
bombs at the box office and the media is
just perplexed by this the governor of
new york not so subtly encourages more
violence against pro-lifers in the
lead-up to the road decision a court
declares that elephants are not people
why was that necessary to establish and
a cnn comedian records a father's day
psa pushing abortion what does that have
to do with father's day we'll find out
about that and much more today
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you are helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes and candidates a
common question i get from my listeners
is what can i do to help turn the tides
in the culture work but here's a great
first step defund the abortionists don't
let them take your money and use it to
further policies you don't believe in
switch to charity mobile today and they
will spend five percent of your monthly
plan price to any uh pro-life charity of
your choice cherry mobile offers the
latest 5g phones with no devices or a
service contracts plus great nationwide
coverage this sounds like a hassle i
assure you it really isn't charity
mobile makes switching from your current
carrier painless their live customer
service is exceptional and they'll guide
you through the process every step of
the way you can keep your number in most
fake cases you can even keep your phone
or if you want
take advantage of my special offer and
get a free cell phone with free
activation all you got to do is call
1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh and join the fight for
life by switching to charity mobile
today
i was quite excited this weekend to hear
the good news trumpeted by conservatives
across social media that reason and
sanity had prevailed in women's sports
fina which is the international swimming
federation has
according to the headlines anyway
banned biological males from competing
against women in elite aquatics
competitions the new rules passed down
on sunday mean that leah thomas's
swimming career is effectively over
tragically he could of course go back to
competing against the men but chances
are that he'll now be even less
competitive against his male
counterparts than he was two years ago
before he began his quote unquote
transition fina's new guidelines do
provide for an open category
where i guess trans athletes who don't
meet the eligibility requirements
to swim against women can compete you
know in the open category so thomas can
perhaps go there and race against
himself where he's sure to once again
dominate but something tells me that
he's not going to see that as a
sufficient compromise as noted most
conservatives have been celebrating the
news seeing it as a as a harbinger of
things to come the beginning of a
movement towards sanity
the new york post headline declares as
much saying sanity returns to
transgender madness after leah thomas is
banned by fina other headlines and
outlets like the daily caller breitbart
outkick
echo this same theme sanity is making a
comeback we're told the tide is turning
one battle has now been won now we march
onward that's the general feeling i
guess
which is why it must
fall to me as always to be the storm
cloud raining on everybody's parade i
hate doing it
actually i kind of enjoy doing it but uh
not in this case i wish i didn't have to
i do though the devil as they say is in
the details and sometimes that is quite
literally the case
and when dealing with the left
you always have to keep this in mind you
always have to dig below the surface to
understand what's really going on these
people did not achieve total cultural
dominance
by being stupid
so what what's what's happening here
well if you go to the organization's
website and you read the new rules for
yourself you'll notice a few things
first under the competitive
opportunities within and outside of
men's and women's categories header
we're told quote
male to female transgender athletes
transgender women
and athletes who have a 46 xy dsd and a
female legal gender and or gender
identity are eligible to compete in the
women's category in fina competitions
and to set fina world records in the
women's category at fina competitions
and other events recognized by fina if
they meet applicable eligibility
conditions
so we see right off the bat
they're not simply banning men from
women's swimming there's more to it than
that a lot more to it it turns out
in fact the new guidelines are nearly 8
000 words long
if it was as simple as establishing or
rather re-establishing that only females
compete against females and males
against males
the policy could be described in like
one sentence
but they take considerably more than one
sentence because only certain males it
turns out are banned from competing
against females
so what does that mean well the policy
explains quote
male to female transgender athletes
transgender women and athletes with 46
xy dsd whose legal gender and or gender
identity is female
are eligible to compete in the women's
category in fina competitions and to set
fina world records in the women's
category in phoenix competitions and in
other events recognized by fina if they
can establish tafina's comfortable
satisfaction that they have not
experienced any part of male puberty
beyond tanner stage 2 or before age 12
whichever is later
specifically the athlete must produce
evidence establishing that
they have complete androgen
insensitivity and therefore could not
experience male puberty or they are
androgen sensitive but had male puberty
suppressed beginning at 10 or stage 2 or
before age 12 whichever is later and
they have since continuously maintained
their testosterone levels in serum or
plasma below 2.5 nmoll
okay
so the problem says fina is not maleness
per se
but male puberty
if a male wants to compete against
females he must transition before
puberty so to block some of the
advantages that maleness would otherwise
afford him
now this rule does indeed mean that leah
thomas is out on his ass
probably means that elite women swimming
will be male free for the foreseeable
future in fact
it's hard to imagine anyone who
transitions before the age of 12 ever
becoming an elite athlete in any sport
given the disastrous effects the drugs
have on the developing human body
the integrity of women swimming has thus
been at least for now
effectively restored so
why isn't it a big win like everyone
thinks it is
because the international swimming
federation
is not at all affirming the binary
reality of human sex
they are not declaring that there's any
inherent problem with categorizing a
male as a female no they said that they
would do that they're happy to do that
they've declared puberty
and testosterone
the enemy
according to them
some women happen to have experienced
male puberty and those women have an
unfair advantage
and so we make a separate category for
them
the solution they say is to block male
puberty from ever taking hold in the
first place
it shouldn't be difficult to see where
the sleeves you don't need a crystal
ball to see 30 minutes into the future
when this will be used as further
justification for transitioning children
earlier
the international swimming federation
has said if you want to participate
fully as a woman you need to become one
much earlier
to the trans activists that simply means
that boys who are supposedly questioning
their gender have to be put on the
medical path even sooner than they
already are
the rules encourage and
validate childhood transitions
many conservatives you know are
celebrating this not thinking about what
they're doing and they're even saying
i've heard from a lot of people they're
hopeful that fina's policy will become a
blueprint for other organizations to
follow
well i certainly hope that isn't the
case
because that will be just more fuel for
the childhood transition fire
it'll be more fodder for the trans
activists
you see they'll declare we can't afford
to wait if your son likes uh the color
pink and plays with dolls get him
transitioned right away
otherwise he'll never be fully accepted
as the woman he truly is inside
this is not pure speculation on my part
as you heard on the show just last week
the world professional association for
transgender health lowered their age
rage guideline age range guideline to
now recommend drugs and surgery for even
younger kids they now advise surgical
sex changes for 15 year old kids and
that age has been dropping precipitously
for years
it's only going to continue to drop
helped along by institutions who declare
early transition as a prerequisite for
full recognition of a person's chosen
gender identity
so this is this is not a win of any kind
certainly not a win for sanity
a win for sanity would be a rule which
simply and clearly declares
that only women compete against women
and only men against men
period end of discussion
no further explanation needed
anything beyond that
any additional considerations
any complications added to the mix any
nuances any uh any uh caveats
only affirm and reinforce that this is
somehow a complicated question
but it isn't
and this is exactly why i've always been
uncomfortable with the way that
conservatives often argue for fairness
in women's sports many of them argue for
it as though their primary concern is
simply fairness in women's sports you
know they argue over women's sports as
if what they really care about is just
women's sports for its own sake
like they really care deeply about
competitive women's swimming itself
and their greatest mission in life is to
ensure that competitive women's swimming
remains fair and
but that's not why i argue for fairness
in women's sports
i argue for it because women's sports is
but one battleground in the overall war
for truth and reason
and if you win a battle but you weaken
your position in the larger war in the
process you didn't really win anything
and here we won something that looks
like fairness in women's swimming but at
the expense of validating and
encouraging the further abuse and
exploitation of children
meanwhile the underlying premise of
gender ideology remains fully intact
in fact these rules and by extension
those celebrating them have reinforced
the underlying premise by agreeing that
maleness and male puberty are two
entirely separate things which can and
often should be divorced from one
another
this is exactly what happens when you
try to cut down a tree
by just like cutting away a few of the
branches
you're not really doing any damage to
the tree
and in fact you may be helping it as as
pruning a tree encourages growth plant
health flower production in the long run
that's what that's what the right is is
unwittingly doing now with gender
ideology they're just sort of pruning
away at it
they're getting it into a better shape
um making it more palatable
for people
you know as long as we have this gender
ideology of madness in our culture as
long as it exists
as long as children are being
indoctrinated into it
then it's probably for the best that we
have the absurd spectacle of men you
know dominating women's sports
that that forces people to confront it
and to see it for the absurdity that it
is
it's actually the best thing for the
trans activists
whether they'll say this out loud or not
the best thing for them is that those
more public displays of the absurdity of
their position go away
but the thing itself remains
so if they can more quietly sort of be
transitioning quote unquote children
indoctrinating kids into this
but we don't have any more leah thomases
that's the best for them that's good for
them
now i say as long as this exists and
we're imposing it on children then there
ought to be leah thomases
in fact it doesn't even make any sense
if we're going to as a society abandon
the difference between men and women
it doesn't make any sense to have the
integrity of women's sports preserved
we don't have a right to women's sports
in a society where we pretend that men
and women are the same
or interchangeable or fluid or whatever
no what we should be doing is drawing a
clear line
and saying to society we have to choose
okay either men and women are the same
and all these things are fluid or not
it's one of the other you can't have it
both ways
if you want to kill the tree you have to
attack it at its roots
and if you really want to restore sanity
in this country
that's the only way to do it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
one of my great uh joys in life is going
to bed each night which is kind of
pathetic but that's the reality of being
an adult and it's all the better because
of my helix mattress if you don't have a
helix mattress yet then you got to get
one and it's very easy helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress that was
made for somebody else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way that you sleep
because you customize it yourself
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for uh obese
sleepers as well so if you're looking
for a mattress you need to take the quiz
you order the mattress that is matched
to you and the mattress comes right to
your door shipped for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again just go to helixsleep.com walsh
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life guaranteed for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners this is their
best offer yet so hurry over to helix
sleep dot com slash walsh
all right we start with uh actually some
movie news from deadline and there might
be more important things happening in
the country but i just thought that this
was uh here's here's some actual good
news something a little a little
something that we can celebrate uh and
this is deadline this is how this is
obviously a left-wing rag and uh this is
how they report on this
they say blame the fact that it doesn't
appeal to girls blame disney plus for
stealing family moviegoers blame the
lack of an ensemble
toy story cast
heck blame everything as disney pixar's
light year didn't do its magic by
internal studio or industry standards
this weekend with 51 million dollars
close to a third below its 70 million
pre-release projection
uh it says this is an opening more in
the vicinity of pixar's original fare
so it could still lag out to 200 million
however given how this ip was built on
the back of the toy story brand it's
clear many were expecting significantly
more
light year overall was down in its
global start um
85.6 million versus the top-end 135
million estimate we reported
so
and it was beat by jurassic world at the
at the box office and uh the long and
short of it is that this new toy story
movie this uh this offshoot
um
light year which again is
this was a film
about the backstory of the of the toy
buzz lightyear in in the world uh in the
toy story world
and it's doing incredibly poorly at the
box office uh way below projections it's
basically a box office dud now
you know for a lot of other movies 51
million dollars would not be anything
close to a dud but given that this is
toy story it's part of the franchise
it's disney all of the marketing and
media and press that went into this 51
million dollars is pathetic
and if you look at some of the headlines
in entertainment media today a lot a lot
of the headlines like this in deadline
they're all trying to figure out what
the heck went wrong how could this have
happened
this is a this is a toy story brand
movie that they're supposed supposed to
do 100 million dollars what's going on
it's a mystery
who could possibly explain this
well it's actually not a mystery at all
um i think there are
a couple of potential explanations here
not potential but
you know absolute
one of them is before we get to the
political part of it one of them is
actually that i think um
there reaches a point
where even the standard moviegoer
with his famously low standards
um
is
just kind of sick and tired of the same
old thing
just the same thing over and over and
over again you're just trying to shovel
the same
garbage into his mouth over and over and
over again
making a franchise out of everything
like the first toy story movie was just
it was a it was a cute little movie
about toys that come to life
and that was what 20 years ago
and 20 years later they're still making
these same things over and over again
so i think there's a there's some
exhaustion there on the movie going on
the part of the movie going public as
well there should be
but even more than that
um is the fact
that this is
the woke toy story
and that's how it was advertised
and that's the that's what the press was
saying
that's the media attention it was
getting
and people don't want that
now
i haven't watched the movie i'm not
going to watch it
as far as i know the only uh woke part
of the film is that they put this
lesbian kiss scene in there between two
characters i don't know if they're toys
or not well you know these are real
people in the in the toy store universe
so these are like real people but
cartoons okay so they're not toys but
there's a lesbian kiss scene
and the media has made uh
much ado about that in a positive way
they're celebrating it
and we know that disney they put that
lesbian kiss scene
in because or they put it back and
originally they had it in the story they
took it out because they figured it
didn't really help the story move along
they needed to cut it for time they put
it back in after the anti-grooming laws
in florida as a political statement
the movie going public wants nothing to
do with that
you know lots of parents they don't want
to bring their kids to a cartoon movie
where there's a lesbian kiss scene
and they also don't want um
entertainment that has a political or
ideological message
they're just sick and tired of it
now
on hollywood's part they can complain
about that and say that oh we we should
have an unending
insatiable appetite for this kind of
thing
we should want this content in all of
our movies if we were truly virtuous
people well
i disagree with that but even if it was
true it's too bad people don't want it
they especially don't want it from their
kids entertainment
okay there's not a lot of parents out
there who want to take their kids to a
movie
and then
um
leave the movie
and that movie is now an opportunity to
have a discussion about lgbt issues
there aren't very many parents who are
looking for that from their
entertainment
so that's why it didn't do well
which is why i would say to hollywood
continue continue doing this all you
want because it's just uh it's just
total self-destruction
you're making yourself
more and more irrelevant
as i've said before i think that you can
find kind of a parallel
this is sort of the bizarro world
version of what christian
entertainment has done for so long
okay the difference is that with you
know so-called christian movies like
christian branded entertainment um they
put just like woke hollywood does now
they put the message before anything the
message is the most important thing the
difference is that with christian
entertainment the message is actually
good so that's that's the good part
but story comes second
plot writing
acting all these things are just after
thoughts
the actual entertainment quality of the
thing itself is an afterthought
and the idea among the christian people
in the christian entertainment industry
is that as long as the message is there
then sort of we've done our job but you
haven't really
because what you should be trying to do
is create great entertainment
that also has the positive message
which maybe means the message can be a
little bit more subtle
woke hollywood's doing the same thing
um
taking the message
only this time it's a bad message
and but the mistake they're making
strategically is they make the message
front and center
they especially did this with that with
this light year movie that's all of the
discussion about the light year movie
it was all about the lesbian kissing
nothing to do with the story
and they're paying the price for it
meanwhile and of course they're not
learning their lessons so star wars we
know that the
star wars franchise in general has gone
woke um has arguably been woke from the
beginning you might even say but uh
their twitter account in particular is
very woke so
they were responding over the weekend
to some random twitter user who said to
them don't make star wars political
and then the star wars account responded
and said
number one queer characters existing
isn't political number two star wars is
literally in our name
not exactly sure what they're going for
with point two but number one they say
queer characters existing isn't
political
well it is though and you've you've
decided that
so you use the quote unquote queer
characters to make political points
that's exactly what disney did with with
the light year film
so no that's that's that's that's
exactly the case
you use these characters for to make
political statements
that was your decision
not ours
people have noticed and they just want
no interest they have no interest in it
they want no part of it
all right uh let's go to this from the
daily wire it says following a slew of
violent attacks on pro-life pregnancy
centers new york governor kathy hokkiel
is inexplicably amping up the rhetoric
against pro-lifers calling them
neanderthals
hawkill on monday signed legislation to
boost abortion quote rights and empower
abortion providers in the empire state
she says this is the united states of
america where freedom and liberty are
supposed to mean something it's the rock
upon which we were founded it is
supposed to mean something except in the
eyes of some neanderthals who say women
are not entitled to those rights
now in the article of daily wire it says
that's inexplicable while she's why
she's doing this but i don't think it's
actually inexplicable at all
this is
we have these terrorist attacks on
pro-life pregnancy centers and uh she is
coming in behind that and saying oh
these are a bunch of neanderthals
obviously the idea is to encourage more
of those attacks
by
primarily by dehumanizing the the in a
very literal sense i think the word
neanderthals here was chosen very
carefully in a very literal sense to
dehumanize pro-lifers
and we know if you dehumanize people
then
you make it easier for
the militants and radicals and
terrorists in your ranks to justify
violent attacks against them
and i don't want to uh
people have been predicting this for
weeks and have turned out to be wrong
but my my prediction is probably this
week we're going to finally get the roe
v wade decision and we know that uh
pro-abortion terrorists have openly been
threatening that once this decision
comes down they're going to go all out
in their attacks on on pro-lifers they
already have been over the last month or
two
and it doesn't matter how bad it gets
there is just no universe where people
like kathy hokule
and other pro-abortion people are going
to come out and
condemn the attacks and tell their own
side to calm down and and let's be
peaceful it's not gonna happen
uh there's no amount of violence that
would propel them to do that
and we saw this of course with the blm
riots in 2020 all right we'll move to
this from the daily mail it says
president joe biden hopped out of church
saturday evening to prove he wasn't
injured after falling over on his bike
during a ride near his rehoboth beach
home earlier in the morning
uh he's in rehoboth beach delaware with
jill to mark their 45th wedding
anniversary and also to mark uh
juneteenth juneteenth weekend so he's
putting all that together so he's got
his wedding anniversary father's day
juneteenth
and um he decided to celebrate all those
things by going for a nice bike ride i'm
sure you've seen this footage a million
times already but let's watch it
together
you and i anyway let's uh let's see joe
biden on his bike
[Applause]
and then he takes a tumble there so he
got it looks like he got his uh he got
his foot caught on the pedal i guess
but he was he was
sitting still on the bike and he fell
over
and i've seen people on social media
trying to justify this and say hey
people fall over on their bikes all the
time do they really i mean i haven't
fallen over on a bike since i was like
seven
now granted i haven't really been on a
bike since i was seven but still
and do they do they typically fall over
so he's got one okay
if you look at the footage there he's
got one foot on the ground
and he's and he's standing still and he
just falls over that doesn't happen very
often even my kids
you don't see that
and you know how you know how
frustrating this has to be for biden's
handlers because they had this whole
thing planned the only reason he went
for a bike ride
was
for the purposes of the camera to prove
that he's still spry and young and
healthy and everything else
um it was just last week that um
uh that the new white house press
secretary gene pear was on cnn and was
actually being asked skeptical questions
on cnn about biden's health and his
fitness for office
and they saw how this is now making its
way into the left-wing media and they
said well we got to do something to
prove that this guy
okay he's he's got he's got another term
in him
that's how healthy he is and energetic
so they thought well well what can what
what can biden actually do
what can the president do
to prove that he's still physically fit
we know he can't walk up steps
we know in fact just walking in general
is a little bit complicated for him so
they said look we'll put them on a
bicycle
that's a good idea
and they had this whole the media
everybody was there all kinds of cameras
all around that are all planned out
everything is going great
all of handler all of biden's handlers
are thinking well this is this is a
great plan this is working out great
we're getting a lot of good press off of
this
we're gonna have all this footage of
buying on a bicycle we can use it during
the campaign this will be this would be
a an ad during the during the campaign
for his re-election
we could just show biden on a bicycle
say look he can still ride a bike
vote for him again
and everything's going great and then he
and then he stops and just falls over
and it ruins the entire
the entire publicity campaign
um because why does that happen well
because he's uh he's 79 years old
losing his mind
not even able to walk
and you have him on a bicycle
maybe next time try a stationary bike
have him go to planet fitness or
something and bring all the media along
and just have them on a stationary
bicycle
in the gym
for like five minutes and get the
footage that way
well even that wouldn't work because
that bike was stationary and he still
fell off of
it and i have to say again
you know there are people laughing about
this and then other people saying well
we shouldn't laugh about an old guy
falling off a bicycle um i disagree i'm
firmly in the let's laugh about it camp
because number one it's funny okay this
is just a fact of life
watching somebody fall off a bicycle
will never not be funny it is always
funny i'm sorry
but number two
i must remind you that joe biden did
this to himself
okay
under normal circumstances i would say
that laughing at an elderly person
as they lose their their mental and
physical faculties
is a cruel thing to do and i would never
ever do that okay i'm not gonna go to a
nursing home a retirement home and just
start pointing and laughing at people
okay
but
he put himself in this position
intentionally
because of his lust for power
so it was his own
lust for power his own narcissism
his own greed
which drove him to run for office at the
age of 78
and now he's reaping
the consequences of that
okay reap what you sow that's what's
happening here this is this is all on
him
and he has it all coming as far as i'm
concerned
all right let's see what else here this
is from the post-millennial
over the weekend it was revealed that
yvaldi police officers didn't attempt to
open the door to the classroom to the
two classrooms where children were
trapped during a may 24th shooting that
left 19 children and two teachers dead
okay did not attempt to open the door
didn't even try to open it a law
enforcement source closed the
investigation told the san antonio
express news that due to a possible
malfunction with door locks inside the
building
the doors to the classrooms where
shooters salvador ramos killed nearly
two dozen people may have been unlocked
the entire time officers were inside the
building and that officers didn't try to
open the door earlier in the standoff
surveillance footage from inside the
building revealed that officers did not
attempt to make an entrance into the
door
and
ramos proceeded to classrooms 111 and
112 which are connected with a door in
between
investigators believe the shooter didn't
lock the doors to these classrooms from
the inside and that they were likely
unlocked the whole time due to a
malfunction
there was also i'm trying to scan for
here there was also a revelation about
apparently an officer had a chance to
shoot ramos as he was going in to the
school or into the classroom
but didn't didn't take the shot because
he was afraid that he would miss and uh
and shoot somebody else
and then ramos goes into the classroom
and is in there slowly executing
children for an hour
and they didn't even attempt to open the
door
now you remember one of the excuses we
heard
for these officers early on is that they
weren't able to get into the classroom
they just weren't able to get in and
that always seemed strange to me
because as i said when this first
happened you know
usually a simple locked door is not
enough to keep police officers out
okay if they think that there's uh drug
money in there they're gonna
bring out the battering ram and just
knock the door down use a crowbar i mean
there are ways of getting inside a door
usually you can't just lock a door and
the police officers will say well never
mind we can't get in the door's locked
so you would think
okay unless they're in unless this is
fort knox or something or he's trapped
inside a bank vault you would think that
they would have a way of easily getting
in the door
but it turns out it's even worse than we
thought
i mean i figured the door was at least
locked
and they didn't make any great attempt
to get in
no they never even turned the knob
um and
every every few days we get another
revelation about this more information
comes out it gets more and more damning
for the police officers
and i i suspect that's just going to
continue because we still don't know
even now you could you could you start
to kind of piece the puzzle together
there's still a lot we don't know
and i think we could probably assume
that this trajectory is is going to
continue
where it just gets more and more damning
for the police officers as we go along
but in some ways it's a pretty simple
story
they were afraid for their lives and so
they didn't go in
and the officer had a chance to take him
out and you know was afraid you missed
then you're gonna be held responsible
for that so just a lot of fear and
cowardice
a very simple story in some ways but
also a uh
an enormous unbelievable
scandal also
all right i wanted to this is a from
from last week and uh i wanted to get a
chance to talk about this a little bit
this is from dnyuz it says an asian
elephant named happy that has been at
the bronx zoo for more than 40 years
will remain there after new york's
highest court ruled on tuesday that she
is not a person in a legal sense and
therefore not entitled to a fundamental
human right by a vote of five to two the
court of appeals rejected an animal
advocacy organization's argument that
happy was being illegally detained at
the zoo and should be transferred to a
more natural environment the dispute
hinged on whether the cornerstone legal
principle of habeas corpus which people
assert to protect their bodily liberty
liberty into to contest illegal
confinement should be extended to
autonomous cognitively complex animals
like elephants but the court said no
chief judge wrote uh quote while no one
disputes the impressive capabilities of
elephants we reject petitioners
arguments that it is entitled to seek
the remedy of habeas corpus on happy's
behalf
habeas corpus is a procedural vehicle
intended to secure the liberty rights of
human beings who are unlawfully
restrained not non-human animals
this is where we are in america we
actually needed a court to declare that
happy the elephant is an elephant and
not a person
and this is actually a complicated
that to you and i it seems pretty simple
we don't we don't need to take this to
court
uh you don't need to read the entire
uh opinion written by this court i
haven't read the entire opinion
then you probably think you don't need
to because it's well it's okay it is the
elephant a person well no how do you
know that well because you just said
it's an elephant and elephants and
people are two different things
so to you and i it seems simple but then
again to you and i the question of what
does a woman seem simple turns out
that's not so simple to a lot of people
in a lot of people's minds
and this especially is not simple on the
left and that's why when this decision
came down lots of people on the left
were upset about it and angry about it
because they think that yeah the
elephant should have personhood rights
an elephant should have personhood
rights
a child in the womb should not
how do you make sense of that well
because on the left
the word person
the label person has nothing to do with
being a human
just as we have this artificial kind of
separation this bifurcation of sex and
gender well they've done the exact same
thing with human being and person
and it's the same answer sex and gender
oh those are two different things well
no they're not they're actually the same
they're synonyms
human being and person
uh are not two separate things they are
they are the same they're just synonyms
they're two words for the same thing
but that's what the left has done and
they've this is necessary in order to
support their position on abortion
now
a person is not necessarily a human
being they say and a human being is not
necessarily a person
well then you have the the question
what is a person
they can't define it
you know maybe that should be the
follow-up to what is a woman we have a
we have a film what is a person
and that to the left is going to seem
even more
complicated i mean just that a a woman a
a person who is a woman that sentence
alone there that's a very complicated
sentence
every word in that little short sentence
is very complicated impossible to define
but if they were to try to break it down
they would say that uh being a person
has something to do with cognitive
ability something to do with
self-awareness something to do with your
you know your uh your faculties your
you know um
your intelligence iq you know they would
wrap all that up in the personhood title
and then that raises all kinds of
questions and if that's the case then um
then okay then you've just made an
elephant a person but obviously unborn
children are not that's what you
intended what about newborn babies what
about uh elderly people with uh dementia
what about joe biden i mean all these
questions are none of them people
and um
you end up with confusion and that of
course is is the whole idea it's just to
take something that once had a
solid understandable meaning
and make it confused
arbitrary
uh impossible to define
and once you've done that it's very easy
because they can come along and
and they get to decide on a case-by-case
basis
who these labels apply to and that of
course is the whole
point
well we all get heartburn at the pump
these days and it seems like there's no
relief in sight especially if you're
waiting around for the biden
administration to make things easier for
you that's not going to happen
but here's the good news um out there in
the free market there are people coming
up with innovations that do make it
easier and one of them is the great app
that if you don't have yet you need to
get it's called upside my listeners are
earning cashback for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free upside app in the app store or
you can go to google play
use promo code walsh for 25 cents per
gallon or more on on your first fill up
that's all cash back very simple easy
don't pay full price of the pup anymore
get cash back using upside just download
the app for free use promo code walsh
for 25 cents per gallon or more on your
first tank and by the way it's not just
for gas you can earn cash back at
grocery stores restaurants take out food
and you can cash out any time to your
bank account or you can get an e gift
card for select retailers and brands
just download the free upside app um go
there right now use promo code walsh to
get 25 cents per gallon or more cash
back on your first tank
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
lego david says you know we hear so much
these days about women's rights gay
rights trans rights etc but we barely
hear anything about children's rights
children have some fundamental rights
that need to be protected and most
people on the left could couldn't care
any less about them except for the part
where they indoctrinate them uh matt
walsh is a true hero one of the very few
defenders of children's rights i don't
know about the hero bit but the rest of
it you're exactly right
uh you know we we take this idea of
rights and then we assign it to
different
groups of people so we have different
labels different types of rights as you
say trans rights women's rights all
these different rights
when really there's only supposed to be
if the word rights has any meaning at
all it's just supposed to be human
rights and anyone as a human being has
those rights
but when the left talks about rights
they don't really mean rights anymore
they mean privileges
okay they mean special accommodations
what they really mean
but if we're going to play this game
and break people down into categories
and then say well here's your here are
the rights you have if you're in this
category here are the rights you have in
this category yeah you would think
that we would do that with children we
would be talking about well here's a
maybe we should have a children's bill
of rights
i wouldn't necessarily support that i
don't think we should need that because
again the the bill of rights that
applies to children should just be the
the bill of rights they shouldn't we
shouldn't need to have a separate one
but um they don't do that with children
and why is that because well because as
we've seen they they hate children i
think it's as simple as that
virginia house says okay i do consider
myself a firm mom that being said
everything you said about kids is so
true and much much more i have three
children had three children the
relationship and bond of parent and
child is so indescribable the love and
pride of someone that you either brought
into this world or even adopted is
amazing and at times overwhelming this
is just the beginning of parental
feelings as much as i love my animals
there's no comparison to how i feel
about my children
i have lost pets and it's heartbreaking
it hurts very badly but there's no hurt
in this world that compares to losing a
child no pain no depth of grief comes
close
yeah well
i very much disapprove of anybody using
the fur mom or fur dead or fur parent
label as i explained on the show
uh because you're not actually the
parent of your pet
but if you're gonna do it then at least
you should be able to demonstrate
that you understand the hierarchy of
these things and that you don't actually
class
your fur child in the same category as
your actual children so i'm glad that
you don't at least
but the way that many pet owners talk
about their pets and treat their pets it
really does seem as though they they
would put their
like dog on the same footing as their
actual child
uh mark says i like the idea of
comparing drag to blackface can we start
calling it drag face it really has a
good ring to it i think woman face works
perfectly fine i think that's what we
should call it actually
cat is table says
um i practically never comment on videos
but i had to say in all honesty the
description of the experience of
parenthood has me pumped to one day be a
father thank you
well it is it's a it's a
you should be pumped about it it's it's
an exciting thing to be a parent
um
let's see
lk 23 says matt why are you so
uncomfortable with birthdays it's so
weird who hurt you as a child
because it i i don't
there are some human things that i can't
understand and relate to i'm like spock
i guess and birthdays is one of them
i just don't understand
why that should be celebrated so i've
existed for another year on earth okay
great
now if if you if you did something
during that year
that is worthy of celebration if you
achieve something then let's celebrate
that i'm all about celebrating
achievements is my point so celebrating
an achievement is great but simply
existing for another year on earth is
not in and of itself an achievement
now if you uh
survived some sort of
life-threatening calamity in the
meantime if you went to war if you
got over a severe illness if your cancer
went into remission or something like
that well then surviving another year is
an achievement but then we're just
celebrating that we're celebrating the
achievement
so i reject on principle
that we should
all be celebrated simply for existing
another year that's my point about
birthdays
uh augusto says two points one i cannot
believe i'm saying this but i agree with
pelosi's statement private beliefs are
private beliefs but they should not
dictate policy that is not a
contradictory position to hold and two
israel drafts women into the military
albeit for two years instead of three
and not into combat roles a society can
exist in a in a democratic sense
and employ that policy
uh well to your second point you know i
don't care what policies other countries
have
some countries draft
children into war
okay my point is that for us
submitting to the drafting of our
daughters into battle
would represent i think just a sort of
full-scale surrender as a society
to your first point
you say private beliefs shouldn't
dictate policy well that
very similar to the people who say you
should never legislate morality right
very similar idea
and just like that idea what you're
saying here makes no sense at all
private beliefs don't dictate policy
okay well let me ask you
what does dictate the policies that a
politician supports if not their private
beliefs
are do you want them to support policies
they don't believe in
do you want them to support policies
that they think other people believe in
but they don't
but even then then they would be
supporting policies based on their
belief
that the beliefs of the public matter so
no matter what they're doing of course
they're going to be motivated by their
own private beliefs
just like every law that is passed
is a is a law that legislates morality
it may be legislating morality wrongly
um it may be legislating morality
ineffectively
it may be legislating the wrong morality
entirely
but every single law that is passed it
is passed because um
the people passing it believe that it's
that it's right that it's good that this
is what we should be doing
you know if if we pass a law making
something illegal it's because we
believe that the thing we're making
illegal
is wrong you shouldn't do it it's
harmful whatever
so it always comes down to morality just
like it always comes down to personal
beliefs
so your point makes no sense but
otherwise thanks for listening and for
leaving the comment big things are
happening here at the daily wire we've
got the most talked about documentary in
america what is a woman if you've seen
the movie now's your chance to read the
book which came out last week and is
available on amazon or wherever you buy
books and we also have the summer movie
tara on the prairie starring gina carano
disney tried to cancel her but we
uncanceled her and now you can see her
like you've never seen her before in
this riveting western that will keep you
on the edge of your seat there has never
been a better time to become a daily
wire member every time you subscribe you
not only make a leftist cry which is the
best part but you also invest in the
future of conservative entertainment and
documentaries that challenge the woke
narrative not only that but your
membership means you can access our
entire library of content including what
is a woman tara on the prairie and so
much more head to dailywire.com
subscribe to join us today that's
dailywire.com
subscribe also speaking of exciting
things i have to tell you my dearest
sweet babies though you are well aware
that i am the most generous of the
theocratic fascist dictators out there
you may still be surprised by this
announcement we are releasing a bonus
installment in my patch program for the
month of june you heard that right i'm
giving you yet another reason to send me
your money over at dailywire.com
shop and so i geniusly if that's even a
word dreamed up a few episodes back the
virtue signal patch and um it's here i i
said we need to make it and just like
with a wave of my hand it materialized
just like that the virtue signal patch
whether it's a blm fist ukraine or the
pride flag the virtual signal patch will
help you maintain the moral high ground
over the rest of society you don't have
to worry about keeping up with the
current thing because you've got the
virtual signal patch and your virtue
signaling and that covers all of it okay
it's a get out of jail free card and
you're good to go if you ask me it's a
sound investment because the pride flag
alone changes too often to justify
purchasing but no matter the cause this
patch will help you stay one step ahead
of the flock by showing your support
for the current thing so get your virtue
signal patch over the daily wire shop
right now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
the comedian w kamal bell is one of
those interesting sorts of comedians who
has made the bold choice to never be
funny like so many other comedians today
bell calls himself a comedian and yet
has never made anyone laugh ever in his
life he's never been involved in a funny
joke
unless his career itself is the joke in
fact bell is so relentlessly unfunny and
uninteresting that he received the most
damning professional indictment
imaginable which is a show on cnn he's
the host of united shades of america
where he preaches about race
i assume i haven't seen it and neither
has anybody else so we can only
speculate
bell was also hired as a spokesman for
something called the abortion access
fund where he produced a father's day
psa encouraging men to celebrate
father's day by supporting women
by becoming a pro-abortion feminist
because that's how you support women
he says
now
we'll play the thing in a minute but and
this is not my main objection that i
would raise to this psa uh we'll get to
those in a moment but
we should note how this is yet another
father's day message that isn't really
for or about fathers
for whatever reason we're not allowed to
simply just celebrate fathers in this
country all of the marketing and
messaging around mother's day is about
how wonderful mothers are but for
father's day we talk about the things
that fathers are doing wrong
father's day is mostly an afterthought
like a participation trophy we give to
dads after all the over-the-top
festivities for mother's day and when it
is acknowledged it's usually to lecture
men about their failures
so we give fathers the gift of nagging
for father's day as if they didn't
already have an endless supply of that
readily on hand but that's neither here
nor there as the problem with this
pro-abortion father's day message goes
way beyond the issues i just raised see
you for yourself check it out
dad does so much for the family this
father's day give him what he really
needs
not a home brewing kit
not socks
give him safe and legal access to
abortion
hello i'm noted male feminist w kamau
bell do you know how much i've spent on
birth control in my life
213 dollars mostly on condoms that
expire to my wallet
you know how much my wife has spent
17
530
[Music]
dads if you've ever had sex and not had
a kid it's likely birth control or
abortion played a role
okay we have to stop it already because
bell has proven that he can't talk about
issues related to the female body
without descending into these amateurish
misconceptions in about 40 seconds
the left you know because they have no
other rebuttal they like to accuse
pro-life men of being sexless in cells
who don't know anything about women i've
always found this charge interesting
given that i have a wife and four
children but it turns out
not surprisingly that pro-abortion men
are the ones who understand very little
about the female body um
the ones who who've actually enjoyed the
company of a woman
because they they managed to find one
with low enough standards to accommodate
them seem to view birth control and
abortion as magical elixirs that simply
make babies and thus their
responsibilities simply disappear they
imagine apparently that without birth
control
a baby would materialize after every
sexual encounter
that's why bell says that if a man has
ever had sex and not had a baby it's
because of birth control or abortion
what he doesn't seem to understand is
that
women are not uh fertile every day of
the month in fact they aren't fertile
most days of the month a woman's body
works in cycles and she's only capable
of conceiving a child for a certain
short period during that cycle usually
about six days which means that
most of the times you've had sex and not
had a baby it has nothing to do with
birth control or abortion in fact
there are couples if you can believe it
who don't use birth control at all and
have sex frequently and don't end up
with 900 kids
that's not a miracle of science it's
just science
and you might want to learn a thing or
two about it before recording another
psa on the subject let's continue
we're used to not having to worry about
it
but nobody ever got pregnant from a
vibrator for that you need
a [ __ ] neck
that's right see the majority of people
seeking abortions are already parents
they know it's right for their families
they would know if having another kid
would send them spiraling into poverty
it definitely would
oh my god
funny you should mention god because
there's literally no mention of the word
abortion in here just like in here
there's no mention of how the state is
going to help these families if they
forced to bear these children it's
almost like this is just a way for a few
fragile men to use religion to control
our bodies
[Music]
so remember the rule here if somebody is
bringing up religion in the context of
the abortion debate it's almost always
going to be a leftist in this case bell
puts pulls out the bible to make the
case for abortion and then the next
sentence accuses pro-lifers of doing the
same he says that abortion is never
mentioned in the bible except that it is
plain as day right in the ten
commandments thou shalt not kill is the
injunction quite famously
actually correctly translated the
commandment is to quote do no murder
this is how jesus quotes the passage in
matthew 19 18 do no murder thou shalt
not murder there are of course many
different forms of murder and many
different ways that people are murdered
and the bible doesn't bother itself with
listing every single potential version
of the crime because there's no need to
if you're killing an innocent and
defenseless human being
you are committing murder and therefore
running afoul of god's commandment
abortion kills an innocent and
defenseless human being and so it is
murder
therefore abortion is mentioned in the
bible now this is not how i would choose
to argue my case if i'm talking to a
secular person
my first point would not be that the
bible forbids it but since he brought it
up
i feel the need to correct the record
speaking of things that aren't mentioned
in places do you know what you know what
uh the bill of rights never mentions
abortion in fact it never mentions
abortion or anything related to abortion
or anything that could be remotely
interpreted as having something to do
with abortion
the word abortion never appears anywhere
in the constitution
abortion is not a constitutional right
but rather a right invented by nine
people in robes in 1973 all of those
people by the way were men
all right now for some reason we're
gonna continue watching this so let's uh
keep going
daddy's doing a psa
okay
ask any parent parenting is a job a
wonderful very difficult job
and since when does america force
anybody to do a job against their will
without paying them by controlling their
bodies
oh yeah right
so as we celebrate father's day let's
also celebrate birth control abortion
and bodily autonomy because man have we
benefited from those
so enjoy your day guys and welcome to
the fight we've been waiting for you
[Music]
i got you socks
parenting is a difficult job he says
which is why parents should have the
option to kill their children instead
and this is the argument the man is
making
while holding his own daughter
it's almost as if pro-abortion activists
are soulless psychopaths i don't know he
also draws a parallel between the
pro-life position and slavery claiming
that we enslave women
by quote forcing them to do a job
against their will the problem with this
comparison is that um being a parent is
not merely a job okay any more than
being a son or a daughter is merely a
job parent
describes a natural biological
relationship this is my whole argument
for why you shouldn't call yourself the
parent of your dog
slavery on the other hand describes an
unnatural oppressive man-made construct
if you're a parent it means that you
have conceived a human being
and that alone makes you a parent by
definition
the job part describes the legal and
moral responsibilities that come with
this relationship slaves have no natural
responsibility to their owners which is
what makes slavery a horrible injustice
parents do have natural responsibilities
to their children which is why nearly
all societies in history including our
own legally require parents to care for
their children or else find somebody
else who will
the only question
is whether that responsibility should
begin at the moment when the child comes
into being at conception or at some
arbitrary point thereafter
pro-abortion people
favor the arbitrary point
in favoring the arbitrary point they
reject the personhood of children before
before the point they've decided
and uh arbitrarily rejecting a human
being's personhood so as to to deprive
that person of basic human rights
and of their dignity
is exactly what happened with slavery
so
bell is right to make the slavery
comparison he just forgot that in this
analogy
he's on the side of the slave owners
the video ends with men being encouraged
to celebrate abortion birth control and
bodily autonomy lumping all these things
together in one category you may recall
that the left used to passionately deny
that abortion is used as birth control
and now they seem to have dropped the
act entirely
now that now he's putting them together
it's the same thing
the relative honesty is at least one
positive thing in this video we can say
but it's not enough to save it and w
kamal bell from being today
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]